We're going to define Fibonacci, so here's
our definition, and let's try this out, so
we'll print the result of fibonacci 0, first,
we should get 0, which we do. We'll
try fibonacci 1, we get 1, so we've seen our two base cases. Now, when
we do fibonacci 2, what we should get is the result of. Fibonacci 1, which is 1,
plus Fibonacci 2, minus 2, which is Fibonacci 0, which
is 0. So we should get 1 again, which we do. And now
let's try printing Fibonacci 3, we get 2.
And if we print Fibonacci 4 we should
get 1 plus 2, which is 3, which we get. And if we try 5,
we should get 2 plus 3, which is 5. And let's try something a little bigger,
let's try Fibonacci 10. We get 55. We'll try
Fibonacci 25, so we'll try Fibonacci 24. So for counting months that would be
the number of rabbits in two years, and we get 46,000. And let's try, in 3
years. Our program times out. So I'm
going to try the soon in the Python interpreter,
well see we can do slightly bigger ones.
But, the time it takes to solve Fibonacci,
this way, is very long. And, the reason
for that is because we're doing lots and lots
of redundant calculation. So, if we look at
what our code is doing. Every time, we call
Fibonacci n, what's happening is we're calling Fibonacci
n minus 1 and we're calling Fibonacci n minus
2. So we're starting, we're calling Fibonacci 36,
that was the example, where the interpreter didn't finish.
And, what we'll get is that's going to
be broken down into calling fibonacci 35, plus
the result that we get from calling fibonacci
34. Each of those is another call to
fibonacci, so the call to fibonacci 35, well
that will be broken into calling fibonacci 34,
and adding that result to what we get from calling fibonacci 33. And when we do
fibonacci 34 here. Well, that's going to be turned into,
calling Fibonacci 33, and adding the result to Fibonacci 32.
We're going to do lots, and lots, of calculations here.
And we haven't got close to getting down, to fibo
1, or fibo 0, which are the only places
that we stop. If we look at the number of
times we have to evaluate, fibo 32, let's pick
that one, so Fibonacci 32. So we need to evaluate,
Fibonacci 32, 1, 2, 3, 4, 5, times. The number of times we had to evaluate,
Fibonacci 33, was 1, 2, 3, times The
number of times we had to evaluate Fibonacci
34 was 2 times, and the number of times we had to evaluate fibonacci 35,
was 1 time, and the number of times we had to evaluate fibonacci 36 was 1 time.
So, maybe you can see a pattern here. How many times
do you think we're going to need to evaluate fibonacci 31?